here you mind if I start a little bit
ahead before this yeah yeah sure no
problem all right so it says uh and when
he came to the place he said to them
pray that you may not enter into
temptation and he withdrew from them
about a stone's throw and knelt down and
prayed saying father if you are willing
remove this cup from me nevertheless not
my will but yours be done yes of course
so you're saying that this is the true
part of the New Testament that's that
the true revelation of the law a strong
man this contains remnants of Truth
contained when he submitted his will to
God you quote see that's where I'm I'm
confused here is yeah sure yes sure so
is the verse that we just read Luke 2242
is that the true part of the New
Testament or not I believe there is like
there's true Parts there's some false
Parts but I'll explain my position on
this verse
particular did yeah sure yeah I'll
explain further because I don't think
you fully comprehended my statement I
believe there's remnants of Truth found
in the Old Testament and the New
Testament and specifically the New
Testament with regards of the life and
supposed death of Jesus Christ of
Nazareth specifically with this verse it
contains a very clear depiction of him
submitting his will to God can we agree
to who to God yes said God to who though
it says yeah it says the father but I
believe that's a corruption yeah I wait
wait wait wait all right so so Paul's
there yes sir So based on the verse that
you came to show that Jesus is a Muslim
based on the true remnant of the verse
it says that Jesus prayed to his father
and Allah's not his father
right Allah father so could we say could
we I mean just based on the verse it
shows that Jesus is not praying to Allah
the god of Islam right so when we look
at this verse in particular it's very
important to realize my stance on the
New Testament I think you keep
forgetting or not recalling this part I
made the explicit statement that the New
Testament contains remnants of Jesus's
life and suppos a death and in this
verse in particular can we agree that
the father is
God yes can we agree that God is the
father based on the verse the God is
that's where we disagree that's where we
wait wait this is what I asked can we
agree that God is his father based on
the verse God is his father yeah we can
agree with that St so when you said and
I understood what you said you said that
there are true Parts in the New
Testament and there are corrupted Parts
in the New Testament so I specifically
asked you where are the true parts of
the New Testament that shows that Jesus
submitted to the god of
Islam I I misheard you that's my fault I
got you a different verse that's my so
you said Luke 20 2242 and I'm like oh
well that's yeah see fine yeah okay well
can can we at least agree here that
based on this verse he can't be a Muslim
by saying that God is his father um it
depends on what sense you're talking
about like a father you say like um
that's the sense you're talking about it
but you said remember you said earlier
that Allah is not a father to anyone in
any sense yeah sure father in any sense
when I'm referring to to any sense it's
not it's more of like a hyperbole if you
put it that way because I'm simply like
exaggerating it like sure so so is it
are we retracting that is there a sense
that Allah is a father I'll retract that
if you want I'll retract that just for
the sake of continuing discussion well
no like not even for the sake of disc
like I really want to know the truth
like you're a real position is there is
there a sense where Allah is a father oh
no not in like um like not like in a in
like a protective sense but not like in
a he is like a literal like father with
a beer stuff like that so there is so
the answer is yes there is a sense in
which Allah is a father there is a sense
but not in the sense you're projecting
it to be I I haven't projected any sense
I haven't projected anything it's no
it's a matter of like connotation like
you know what I mean got it so so it
matters the the the connotation it
matters the sense in which you use it so
Allah is a father in some sense yeah
like very very specific sense but yes
and what in what sense is that like he
is like the creator of the universe that
doesn't mean father father does the
father uh does a father have authority
sure does but so does a a lord or a
master not a father don't have to be
father does a father have authority over
his children uh yes but so does someone
who's not a father like a teacher or a
lord or a master someone a babysitter
yeah sure but in this specific example I
use a father has authority over what a
child says or does okay does a mother
also have authority over a child or what
he says or does yeah so in some sense
can we call a mother Allah mother in a
loving sense fully fully merciful yeah
that sense not disagree with that so yes
we can call Allah mother in that sense
that sense where he's so loving but it's
not where he's loving and he's nurturing
yeah loving Allah's most gracious most
merciful so I can still just like cuz I
just want to be clear so I can still be
a Muslim and believe that Allah is my
mother who loves me and takes care of me
and and you know nurtures me yeah mother
and like in the sense you're in the
sense of like being the most great in
the really loving like that's the way to
conceptualize it no no problem you got
just just make it clear to just you know
knowing your
position yeah cool cool cool okay nice
nice all right so go ahead show me the
verse that uh yeah
sure I see the side chat they're all
laughing and stuff it's fun though it's
f are you Sun oh yeah awesome awesome
okay cool I I mean I appreciate you
being honest man I appreciate you being
honest with yeah why would I why would I
be dishonest man you know I get I get
you know you can imagine I get a lot of
people who are like here just to argue
they're not here to be be real yeah I
came here to discuss the Trinity but
like I'm GL discuss with you this point
with the New Testament no
problem let me look at this trying to
find explicit verse more explicit than
most because most I will agree the New
Testament is a document that pushes
certain Concepts yes it it has a
specific theology that is speciic
theology we would disagree what that
theology is for
sure you sure you won't get in trouble
for for saying that yes Allah can be
your mother if I get if I get in trouble
then like I don't is it like um like an
like
what by other Muslims like or or you
know yeah if I'm not all want speci top
then sure
yeah but I never said like mother in the
sense of like like my mother has like
hair never said in that sense BL yeah no
not not a physical sense but you know
just like you know like that e position
like all his body parts so like stuff
like that it's like really it's very
debated among like Scholars of Islam
that he has body parts um specifically
the interpretation on like what those
body parts are like are they like
metaphysical unlike creation are they
like similar to like you know I mean
stuff like that it's really semantics
yeah yeah yeah okay okay I got you sure
yeah
sure because the biggest thing about the
Old Testament it's really hard to find a
verse where it says God because um it's
a historical def find like go work such
a g it's very historical tossed around a
lot uh
[Music]
huh you've been a Muslim all your life
oh yeah okay okay
okay come on man it shouldn't be that
hard to find out no the uh it's a very
big book man gota be
there's only there's only a few parts of
it that's true right a few parts uh it's
mainly I think the it's debated on like
what parts are like corrupted to some
extent what parts are uncorrupted I can
make the basis and the claim that the
corruption of the New Testament can be
based off like the father not being
called like God or something no you
can't you can really make that argument
you can't I can't you cannot I cannot
why because you have no type of basis or
evidence for that at all not basis no
basis so if I find documents with the
term G do in
them if you find like for example if you
find a document of Luke 22:42 an earlier
one than what we have where father is
not used but it's God instead or Theos
something like that uhuh yeah then you
know be my guest you got me because I
would go to
versus like um John 8:42 I would go to
verses such as that like um I think it
says he did not come on his own God sent
him he says the father sent him he says
the father sent him yeah that I think it
depends on the translation you come to
but trying to find a verse no it's not
it doesn't depend on the translation
every if a translate if Jesus said
father in the verse every translation is
gonna say father I'll take I'll take
I'll take you up on that I'll take you
up on
that there's never a a a variant where
Jesus uses father and maybe another
manuscript may just have God there or
and not father there's there's not
there's not a man there's not that
doesn't exist yeah sure no problem gra
this if you want I'll concede because I
can't find one right now I to get back
to you Sunday one I love sure I don't
time that's fair enough so this is where
this is where I guess this this puts us
for now that based on the historical
document that we have on Jesus's life we
can see that he was not a Muslim he did
not believe in things that line up with
Islam can we agree I don't believe the
the New Testament is an historical
document to get reliable information
about people like Jesus sure I will
conce all sure how you do you do believe
that the New Testament is historical and
reliable okay sure okay sure how you
said how yeah how what what language is
you to speak uh Aramaic how do you know
that uh Aramaic due to the maybe the
Landscaping where he was maybe the what
land uh depending on the
geographic landscape like where he was
where the common languages were spoke
how do you know that he was in a place
where Air Mag was the spoken language I
don't know I don't remember it comes in
the New Testament comes from the New
Testament already yes but here's another
thing here's another layer to that
because well what if I well I did make a
claim originally that the New Testament
is a document reliable enough for um
certain pieces of information
yeah but see at the same time you just
said it's not as it's not historically
reliable historically reliable in the I
just showed you that it is we can show
you remnants of like the New Testament
being a reliable document and unreliable
document for certain claim what what
what determines whether or not this this
is a this is actually true historically
reliable or well I wouldn't look at the
me personally but I would look at the
historians and most historians and
Scholars op but the historians are using
this using the New Testament as a
primary source on Jesus so that's that's
yeah sure if I what what about Bartman
then Bart uses the New Testament as his
primary source on Jesus but what else
does he critique about the New Testament
well he just he just doesn't you know
believe every word and then he doesn't
believe oh really that he he he doesn't
he doesn't believe that uh you know like
the people who are named have written
him wrote it or yeah yeah sure you know
he he has his he has his most Scholars
like most Scholars well I wouldn't say
most Scholars I would say
I would say that the number same number
of Scholars disagree with Barner and the
same people on the same level disagree
with him okay sure yeah but what I'm
saying what what I'm saying is that
regardless all of these Scholars still
use the New Testament as their in
primary information on the life of Jesus
all of them yeah all of them okay yeah
so they even is showing you that the New
Testament is historically reliable for
the life of Jesus even though they don't
believe everything but it's the it's the
source that we get the life of Jesus
where he was what language he spoke
where he grew up where he preached who
he was acquainted with you know what the
problem
was so then what do you know about I
have a question for you actually what do
you know about most Works done by the
preservation of the New Testament what
uh what people do you know have
critiqued this besides not not that much
that's not my field I'm I'm very surface
level on that very surface level okay
sure when we specifically look at the
critique most people do of the New
Testament we specifically um or the
preservation and the reliability as a
document it's mainly come down to the
authorship of the New Testament mainly
come down to that that's a very surface
level critique but it is a important
point to mention auth of them well well
one I I don't I don't think so because
think so okay no because if we if you
are if they're using these as eyewitness
testimony and saying well we don't know
exactly the names of these witness but
based on the contents we can see that
it's eyewitness testimony that's all you
need you don't have to have sure so you
know you know for Hadith for something
to it has to good like it has to have a
good
isad sometimes sometimes so it's the I
don't know about sometimes I think
depending on like your sector or like
whether you're Shia Sunni I I think it I
think that even the the Hadith me method
is is inconsistent man because you think
Hadith science is not a good way to get
a good description of let's say people
like well I don't I don't think that you
guys you guys don't use it for
everything you guys don't use everything
yeah sure we use like we as Muslims we
use Quran as primary source and we use
Hadith as secondary source yeah but like
you would need if you're if you're if
you're using like okay this is how we
can objectively see if a Hadith chain is
authentic right yeah um you then that
would be an objective standard you can
use for everything even the Quran
right so you would need a a sah chain
for the Quran you would chain of
transmission that's what you're
referring to with a chain of
transmission but not just that though
but also to even go further you would
need a chain to this inil that the Quran
mentions a chain to the Torah oh yes yes
in yes yeah so you you would need like
to be consistent you got to apply that
standard to everything in Islam yeah
sure does the does do we um what does
the Quran say about do you know it says
a lot says it says it says a lot and it
says nothing at all at the same time all
sure yeah sure so let's look
at let's look at what the Quran says
about Theo because I've seen you argue
that Theo is the New Testament I've seen
you argue this point before I disagree
with that point personally you disagree
I disagree with that what because I want
to ask you a question I want to ask you
a question hold on a second hold on a
second Omar hold on a second yeah you
just hit the button baby
and we're back ladies and gentlemen with
another segment of what is theel we have
ourselves a new contestant here our
friend Omar let's all welcome Omar
ladies and gentlemen what up oh yeah all
right so Omar says that he does not
believe that the angil is the new
testament which means he knows what the
inil is so go ahead Umar tell us what
the um that's a straw man of the
position first of all and second off the
Quran makes an explicit claim of the
inil as being the message given to the
ISA the message given to Jesus okay and
what was that it's uh in the that preach
the Shia it's most interpretations let
me grab it for you where does the Quran
say that the that the Sharia is in the
yeah sure no problem let me grab you it
it's not word for word bar for bar the
type of thing but I'll grab okay I'm not
I'm not that strict
sure no problem we can use understanding
when we when verses are pulled up you
know use our use our
comprehension so let's first off like
identify the inil so it's in Surah 3 ay
3 Al IM if you know what that is of
course of course I know what that is um
what I said yes I know what that is yeah
sure you want to pull it up or I'll put
it up you said three three right yeah
three yeah okay send down the book
confirming you know what came before and
he sent down the Torah and the
gospel you know yeah sure and then in
the next verse it says previously as a
God for the people and revealed the
decisive Authority surely those who
reject Allah's revelation will suffer
severe in torment for Allah is Almighty
capable of punishment surely nothing on
Earth and in Heavens is heard is hidden
from Allah okay we agree yes so we know
that the injil is a revelation from
Allah we know that theel was given to
Jesus but what was that so in the text
from what we know what the Ang is it
says specifically in uh Surah 3 Ayah 48
and he will teach him the writing on
wisdom and the Torah and the gospel so
I'm gonna go to 48 and read out loud for
you so for I have
48 yeah sure it says Mary wondered my
Lord this is in 47 just to give you
context Mary wondered my Lord how can I
have a child when no man has ever
touched me and the angel rad so will it
be Allah creates at what what he wills
and when he decrees a matter he simply
tells it be and it is and Allah will
teach him writing and wisdom the Torah
and the gospel so teaching the writing
the wisdom the Torah and the gospel yeah
sure and in the next verse it says a
messenger to the children of Israel I
have come to you with a sign from your
lord I'll make you I'll make for you a
bird from clay breathe into it and
become a real bird by Allah's will I
will heal the blind and the leper and
raised the dead to Life by Allah's will
and I will prophesize what you eat and
store in your houses surely in this this
is a sign for you if you truly believe
what is that what is that gospel though
all of this doesn't help us what is sure
in the next verse it further clarifies
I'll confir the Tor the next verse does
not help us yeah it will hold on you got
it literally does nothing to answer the
question of what the gospel is it does
nothing hold on hold on y'all let me
cook
here let me cook let me quick all right
go ahead then I'll go to this one let me
double check my facts real quick before
I spew off a little
bit hold on
uh let me I'mma hold on I'll be right
back let me give me a moment I gotta use
the restroom where you going oh you use
restroom all right ladies and gentlemen
we are at a commercial break let's go
ahead and play our play our commercial
song while our friend
um make sure you guys hit the like
button and subscribe to the channel this
is the segment what is the nil and our
contestant is confident our contestant
is precise our contestant is sharp and
he might be the best contestant that
we've ever had in this segment of what
is the n so we've established y'all that
the inel is a revelation from Allah
we've established that
was taught to Jesus it was given to
Jesus but the only question that we're
still asking is what is it so when our
contestant gets back I believe that
that's what he'll tackle and tell us
what is
the in the meantime make sure you guys
are hurting the like button make sure
you guys are subscribing to the channel
if you love these discussions if you
love these Interfaith dialogues if you
love these engagement and you learn from
them make sure you subscribe make sure
you give this uh Channel a follow if
you're on Tik Tok make sure you follow
us all right we're live all the time
Monday Wednesday and
Friday Sunday is a special time you know
decided to go live you know especially
for this so also subscribe to oneway
apologetics who uh inspired this live
stream because we were doing a uh review
earlier all right there we go let's get
to some super chats here
we got Pierce Taylor who says God bless
oh he's back back all right awesome
awesome awesome awesome he's back ladies
and gentlemen he's back he's back he's
back sure yeah all right yeah use the
rest my fa no it's all good man it's all
good it's all good so that's sure what
is the inil now so the inil to my
understanding of the Quran and Scholars
I'll say because uh we don't only face
our we're not we're not we're not kest
we don't to bed our our entire religion
from
Quran especially made this statement as
well um feel back back and go and it's
the it's consistent with the Shia and
I'll grab you from some people some
Scholars Z you saying theil is
consistent with the Sharia consistent
with the it is Shar like we believe that
like every Prophet preached the same
message okay you believe that every
Prophet preached the same message so did
every Prophet preach the inil every po
every like um the Sharia it's called the
Sharia it's like you know like Sharia
law it's laws based off of Islamic
principles and Islamic principles is
like Sharia and the term Sharia is like
Islamic values got it so every Prophet
preached Islamic
values but e even though their message
may have varied you know depending on
their time and the and the audience they
came with right yeah okay so that's what
I'm trying to figure out specifically
D what was that what is
that let me grab the
scholar real quick I just I don't want
to spew out of just like nothing
really
okay
uh you grab a reputable thing real quick
I don't want to grab the that Source
real quick
commentaries
uh youing maybe I yeah I'm looking at
like theer stuff like
that uh let me grab I'll sent a link in
the side shots this contains every
commentary for tough seers on
378 okay specifically talks about
the and even talks about with C the Jews
author Allah's words
yep words and meanings with their
tongues uhhuh yep sure and then let me
grab let me grab an explicit statement
about the
agus
okay I don't think we're gonna find it
in that in that top Ser of 378 yeah I
think yeah this specific talks about
like I'm usually it was um this talks
about like the CR option specifically
from for the Islamic standpoint through
Scholars such
ASI stuff like that people like that
yeah what is I forgot this kid's
name this guy's
name
um uh
yasti uh I think it's um uh do you know
uh Adan Rashid you know who that is yeah
yeah do you know what that is I think he
talks about that a lot he talks about
what theil is he doesn't even know what
it is huh he doesn't even know what it
is he's not
even huh he's not a scholar and he
doesn't know what the top SE
is
yes let me grab I think I'm pretty sure
has credentials
no he not a scholar
I'm
sure he's he's an historian though he's
Adan rashed Adan Rashid yes no he's not
yes he's a distinguished historian what
do you mean Adan Rashid the one who's
debated you know James Dr James White
and all these people that guy Adan
rashed that
guy I put him in I put him in the link
in the in the private
chat that's the GU I'm referring to he
talked
aboutus that he's an
historian even this guy's definitely he
has credentials that's all I know about
to see what you talking about about to
see what you talking about I'm 99% sure
that's yeah n Rashid
bro yeah historian he has an honors
degree from the University of
bro why you
them guys no man Anan rashed is not is
not a is not just scholar dog he's an
historian I said he's a historian what
do you mean he's you're saying he's a
historian no I I didn't say yeah he's an
historian with a honors degree in
history from the University of Len okay
what does he say the in is man I think
he makes the explicit CL of theil is a
message given to isaam was the
expressive
message what what what is that the
message given to ISA like look bro we
know that we know I have a video I have
a video I have a video I have a video I
play it in the mic play in the mic
you're playing a video oh yeah BR I
can't put into the same words
man oh come on
Omar this is not how this segment
supposed to go supposed to go how's it
to go then curious supposed to know what
the inil is or just say you don't know I
mean if I I will never concede on this
point I'll never concede on this point
you'll never concede on what the injil
is no I'll never concede yes you will
yes you will who say so you I think you
will you you I don't think I don't think
I will I don't think I will man you're
Hest guy so far if I think if it comes
to a point where you know a concession
is necessary I think you'll concede for
sure I I I have I have a really good
thing I have a really I have a really
good way to prove this really good way I
really way to prove
this so if if I show you that he
preached Islam in the Quran will you
accept it no because that's just a claim
yeah just a claim but when I give you
the sense of the and I give you the
interpretation of what the is based on
the Quran would you accept it I I will
accept what the Quran is saying however
I need it to tell me what it is see look
I know what the Quran says it says a few
things about the NGO one it's a
revelation of Allah two it was given to
Jesus Jesus is the one that preached it
three it was written down eventually
four the Quran confirms it five the
Christians are supposed to judge by it
so with the with the Quran as an
authority no not with the on at all no
are wait wait wait wait wait why do you
wait wait wa
wait get to that in a second okay I'll
that later problem all right so these
are the things that the Quran says about
the NGO okay but it doesn't tell us what
it is exactly it doesn't tell
us okay sure no problem see you just
conceded so sure no no I you know what
I'm going to say right I have an idea
we're gonna we're going to use Quran to
prove this so inviting you to I have an
idea I have an idea I have an idea I
have an idea so when we go to S 548
right it says that like the book uh he
says he said we have revealed to you oh
Prophet like that's on that Big Picture
This Book with the truth as a
confirmation for as a confirmation of
previous scripture says that and and
supreme authority and um and a suprem
Authority it doesn't say supreme
authority it says Guardian MIM Guardian
oh yeah you're right actually so judge
between them by what Allah has F and you
now follow their desires of the truth
has come to you this this is this is
Allah speaking to the prophet
Muhammad and then in the next
verse I'll keep read I'll keep reading
it I'll keep reading it yeah but I think
you already know what this is but I'll
read out for you no problem yeah to each
of you we have ordained a code of law
and a way of life if Allah had willed he
would have made you one Community but
his will is to test you with what he has
given you so complete with one another
in doing good to Allah you will all
return then he will inform you regard
your differ each so to each of you he
has prescribed to them their their own
law which groups is he talking about the
Jews and the Christians Jews and the
Christians and the Muslims yep all right
so Jews they have the Torah Christians
they have the gospel Muslims they have
the Quran if he wanted to if he will he
would have made more Community he would
have made them more Community exactly so
even in Muhammad's time their books the
Torah and the gospel are still good for
them to use for judgment in their
criteria right yeah yeah yep got it all
right this still doesn't tell us what
theel is yeah but it tells you in the
next
verse the next verse doesn't tell us
anything about the yeah yeah sure but do
you believe do you hold to the position
just had like strict question like do
you hold to the ability or do you hold
to the position of the New Testament is
the
NG uh we we'll see we'll see okay okay I
think you do I think you do that we'll
see my my my my whole thing here is how
do you know it's not that's my whole
thing how do you know theil is not the
New Testament dude this this is this
happened with daa and the other guy it
sure did it definitely did and I I saw a
clip where the New Testament comes after
Jesus right the New Testament comes
after Jesus that is correct so can
something be revealed after Jesus be
revealed to uh can something that came
after Jesus to Jesus who says that it
was revealed after
Jesus who said it was revealed after
Jesus yeah nobody says is revealed after
Jesus it was just written after Jesus
written after Jesus okay so what is uh
what is like the I believe you hold in
that the Gospel of Jesus like the words
of Jesus the like the teaching so so
it's it's like it's like this bro it's
like this if if Jesus revealed the
gospel right he went around preaching
the gospel right and then let's say five
six 10 years years after he ascended to
Heaven his companions decided to write
down what he preached yeah there's no
problem with that right it doesn't mean
that that's when it was revealed yeah it
was revealed when Jesus preached it but
they just happened to write it down
later yeah there's there um in the New
Testament especially it talks about how
like many things were like many thing
many um things were said that they
didn't uh have on record like many
things Jesus said that yeah many no well
well many things he did that they didn't
have on record yeah many things he did
have on record yeah with another guy
yeah okay so so with with this being
said now the question still stands how
do you know that the inil is not the New
Testament how do we know because you
hold to the the New Testament teaches
the doctrine of the Trinity um
supposedly teach the doctrine of the
Trinity do doctr I don't believe so I
don't believe so okay so it doesn't
matter what I believe yeah sure yeah but
but with the position I held previously
how the New Testament contains remnants
of truth of
Isa okay in this verse in this verse in
this verse in the in Sur 5 aah 49 it
says and judge between them oh Prophet
by what Allah has revealed and do not
follow your desires and beware so they
do not lure you away from some of what
Allah has revealed to you if they turn
away from Allah's judgment this has
nothing to do with with this with the it
will it will it will let me Circle back
let me Circle back the question the
question is how do you know the inil is
not the New Testament my brother because
it teaches anti-islamic values but that
doesn't mean that it's not the that that
would just mean that the taught
anti-islamic
values the taught anti Islamic values
yes and the Quran is confirming a book
that contradicts Islam that's all that
that's all that would mean okay I have a
question if the is the New Testament
then like what Cannon is it wait no
that's that has nothing to do with the
question we deal with that next I
promise you but first let's establish
what the heck thean Jill is first so do
we do we do we see at least so far that
you have nothing to stand on you have no
basis to say that the New Testament is
not the N no
basis
uh no basis I would say like I do have a
basis what's your basis basis would be
like I don't know like scholarly
interpretation but I just can't find
that right now scholarly interpretation
that the scholars use the New Testament
a lot of times in their interpretation
yeah but like the Islamic scholars in
particular matter of fact you yeah
Islamic scholars matter of fact when we
look at a particular commentary of the
Quran look watch this when we go to
7157 I'mma show you what a commentary
does can you stop smacking in the mic my
father's eating I
know
look and let's use Hal let's see what
the two Scholars said when we look at
this translation of the
Quran look I have it over here on the
right this is
7157 those who follow the messenger the
prophet who can neither read nor write
I.E Muhammad whom they find written with
them in the tat and then they quote my
Bible Deuteronomy chapter 18 verse1 15
and the inil the gospel John 14 verse 16
yeah sure even commentaries say that the
inil is our Bible wait what scholar is
this is this who is this this is this is
halali and Khan these are two Scholars
together are they are they are they um
what's like their what's their school of
thoughts what's I I don't know that deep
all right all all right
all know I don't know I ain't that deep
on that yeah you know but just but just
just showing you that even Islamic
scholars appeal to the Bible and say
let's say let's say let's say I concede
thees in the New Testament let's say
that hypothetically it ain't it ain't no
let's say it do you I will never conceed
that never why I'm gonna keep fighting
bro I'm gonna keep looking for evidence
bro and if if it's true then I'll Contin
like fine like it's like okay whatever
good but in the Quran specifically when
inah 5 ay 49 it says and judge between
them by what Allah has revealed and do
not follow their desires and be aware so
they do not lure you away from some of
what Allah has revealed to you if they
turn away then no this referring to the
judge between who judge between who
judge between them them old Prophet them
the Jews and the Christians beautiful so
not the books themselves but the people
right's them Christians yeah like um
like what Allah has revealed right so so
you have and this is what the Quran says
over and over again matter of fact you
you saw this in chapter 3: 78 how it
says they distort God's words with their
tongues they lie about I sent you scly
interpretation well I I already know the
verse but this is the point
yeah is that the scriptures according to
the Quran are good they're good for
judgment they're you're supposed to
believe in them they're intact however
the people don't follow their scriptures
and sometimes they lie and misinterpret
them so Muhammad is saying judge between
them and don't follow their vain desires
so that they don't lead you away Lead
You astray with their lies and
misinterpretation I'm gonna grab I'm
gonna grab something I'm gonna grab the
the T SE for that real quick yeah
just just showing you that you're
judging with the Quran is like saying to
judge between the people don't follow
their vain desires their lies their
distortions and stuff like that when
they try to lead you away has nothing to
do with the scriptures themselves the
scriptures themselves they're good and
pure so um where we're at is is that the
Quran affirms the the
scripture but tells you to watch out for
the people yeah I'm going to send a link
in the thing but for this look at the I
sent the private chats this is Quran the
Stu here for
49 and it talks about it says here in
the in the in the fifth for and in the
sixth verse the address of is to the
holy prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam saying that to him Allah has
revealed them Quran which confirms the
Torah in the books previous to it and is
their C custodian as well this is
because after the people of the Torah
altered the Torah and the people of
theil made changes in theil it was the
Quran alone which turned out to be kind
of the overseer and protector which
exposed the alterations made by them L
up truth and reality in their proper
perspectives right so that's I which
he's one of those who holds the position
that the scriptures has have actually
been corrupted but that's not all of
their opinions y like when you
never made that claim yeah when you go
to when you look at I Abbas on 378 he
says None can change the words of Allah
none can take and remove any of the
words from any of his books but that
they only distort their apparent
meanings so you have this is common
though I will say this is common among
scarly interpretation with specific ver
the Quran and this mainly depends on
like your like um your school of
thoughts and what like se you take
exactly so you have two you have
actually there's three groups that Ian
cam who's also a contemporary of iier
Ian cam gives us three groups that have
three different positions there's the
group like iir they believe that the
scriptures have been corrupted and
changed textually yeah right then
there's the other group that does not
believe that they've been changed
textually but that they've just been
misinterpreted and distorted with their
words right their lie about what they
say yes and then there's the third Group
which is the smaller group which IA is
part of who says that most of the
scriptures is intact but some of it like
there's a little bit of it that's been
cor yeah like some examples could be
like referring to like the father or
something like that maybe like some of
that like that look at you yeah so so
this is where we're at man um based on B
but based on the Quran we still I mean
to me I think it's clear that the Quran
would be leading I mean the inil is
leading towards the the uh New Testament
that's the inil that the Christians had
that's the gospel that they had was the
New Testament yeah um and the Quran
affirms it it says it's with them it's
in their
possession and uh that's what they were
using so it looks like everything's
pointing to that theil is the New
Testament
right uh I don't know I'm not bro like
whatam call it I want to go to college
for like religious studies and
philosophy so I think I'll definitely
have more of a sent Stone position of
what theat is that's fine I'll definely
have more of a clear position but it
leads towards that realm of like thought
and discussion it leads towards the
realm that it's the New Testament is
that right yeah but like yeah it leads
towards that it leads towards see I I
didn't I tell you in the beginning I
said you would concede because not
because you're like defeated or like I
didn't win anything here but you're just
honest you're you're if it makes sense
to you I said you're gonna concede and
so and here you are you're like okay
yeah you know what it looks like it's
leading to the fact that the it is the
New Testament however I just to add on
to that specifically with among scholar
the scholars you should very well known
this among Scholars there are
disagreements among like what theist
this is very prevalent among even like
Shia sunnis no matter the sector no
matter what their is whether
the Sal Maliki doesn't matter really
what they are and really it's down to
the fact and what you can really get
from this is that the Shar or like theat
and the teach the core message of the sh
or Islamic values that's what you can
really derive from it but you don't but
you don't know that for sure you don't
know I mean like bro like you gotta you
gota You Gotta Give Me You Gotta like
you know what I mean like what I don't
know I don't know how to WR it but like
sure all right look hey Umar you are
welcome back anytime bro live Monday
Wednesday Friday so come back again I'm
gonna let the next guest up though this
was fun I had a good time with you bro
all bro all right take care man all
right guys and that's our second of what
is the inil and nine times out of 10 if
the Muslim is honest it is going to lead
to the inil
being the New Testament